hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm one of the most
common questions I'm asked is hey Kevin
what are the best openings in chess that
I should study this typically comes from
newer players getting into the game
possibly watching a few of the videos
and realizing there's too many different
openings to learn all of them so they
kind of want to narrow it down and
figure out what they should work on
first
it also will come from chess players
that maybe they've been playing for a
while but they really only know a couple
openings and they want to figure out
maybe some other ones that are popular
or that maybe may fit their specific
playing style a little bit better so I
thought it'd be cool to go over the top
ten chess openings that I think every
chess player should know they all have
different facets to them some are more
for aggressive players some are more
from passive players they like to
counter-attack later in the game so it
has something for everyone
so without further adue the top ten
chess openings
the first opening we're going to look at
is the Slava defense one of the more
popular ways to defend against the
Queen's Gambit so pawn to d4 pawn to d5
Queen's Gambit is pawn here to c4 and
then the Slav offense is pawn here to c6
very very sound defense one of the more
common ways that you'll see grandmasters
defend against the Queen's Gambit if
they're not playing an Indian defense
style play which we have a indian
defense later on in this top 10 list but
very very strong defense from black and
since the Queens gambit is one of the
more popular openings in all of chess
having a strong way to combat that is
always very good
the next opening we're going to be
looking at is from white and it's pawn
to a d4 pawn to d5 Bishop f4 Knight f6
and then Knight to f3 this is the London
system doesn't have to be in this
specific order but it's all about
getting these pieces and pawns to these
specific squares typically the dark
square Bishop for white is one of the
least common utilized minor pieces in
the game and so having an opening you
always want to have more than one d4
opening in your repertoire besides the
Queen's Gambit that's very very common
but Bishop here to f4 kind of changes
things up and definitely a very very
solid opening to have four White's
in your opening repertoire
the next opening we're going to be
looking at in their top 10 list is the
cour con previously in our first defense
we looked at how to attack the Queen
pawn opening and this one we're going to
be looking at the King pawn opening
efore it's going to be the same series
of move so its pawn to c6
it usually continues with pawn to d4 and
then black and push forward with pawn to
d5 so as you can tell
same pawn structure as before as the
slob defense but this is more attacking
that first move of pawn here to e4 so
Cara Khan definitely needs to make sure
that you're familiar with this and your
chess openings
the next opening in our top 10 list is
the fried liver attack one of my
favorite attacks because I'm making the
list I get to put some pretty aggressive
openings in here and since I'm a pretty
aggressive player the fried liver attack
is obviously going to make my list if
you're not too familiar pawn to e4 pawn
e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop to c4 and
then after Knight to f6 White's going to
bring his night up here to g5 attacking
with his Bishop and his nights here on
d5 to f7 and then if his opponent
decides to go ahead and try to stop that
with pawn here to d5 we're going to play
pawn capturing after the knight captures
then this nights going to sacrifice here
on f7 so if you like to sacrifice this
is definitely going to be one of your
go-to openings because it's just really
fun who doesn't want their opponent to
bring out their King and then they bring
their Queen involved and they just chase
their opponent's pieces all over the
board so definitely definitely one of my
top 10 openings in chess
the next opening in our top 10 let's
list is the French defense probably one
of the more annoying defenses I think to
play against but pawn to e4 and then
pawn here to e6 getting ready if white
plays pawn to d4 to push forward with
pawn to d5 very solid defense from black
so I definitely recommend if you play
against efore a lot that you study this
because it gives black a lot of
opportunities to counter on the Queen
side very easy as these pawns are
pointed towards the Queen side to push
forward with pawn to c5 to get your dark
square Bishop involved into the game to
even get your queen involvement to the
game after you play your pawn up here to
c5 so a lot of different ways the French
defense although I don't like playing
against it is a very very solid defense
against pawn to e4
the next opening for whites we're going
to be looking at is the right Lopez it's
the first opening I've learned in chess
it may be the first opening that you
learned in chess but if you don't know
much about it you should definitely
study it because you'll probably see it
it's that common probably one of the
most common openings in all of chess
pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6
and then Bishop to b5 a lot of different
ways that it can go from here you could
have the morphe defense white can either
take if you wants to with the exchange
variation you can always bring his
bishop back here to a4 then castle so a
lot of different ways this can go but
definitely the right Lopez needs to be
on your list of top 10 chess openings
that you should know
the next opening we're going to be
looking at our top 10 list is the
nimzo-indian defense great way to attack
the Queen's Gambit to pawn here to d4
Knight f6 pawn to c4 this is the Queen's
Gambit and then we have pawn to e6
Knight c3 and Bishop here to B for
blacks already putting a lot of pressure
on white he's threatening a double pawn
here on the C file he also hasn't really
committed anything with his pawn
structure so it's pretty flexible for
black the Indian offenses have grown in
popularity for both sides of the board
the the Kings Indian defense the Queen's
Indian defense that nimzo-indian defense
is a very very strong opening you
definitely should have in your top 10
list of chess openings to know
the next opening in our top 10 list is
my favorite opening so if you watch me
in my videos you probably are familiar
with this but it is the King's gambit so
pawn to e4 pawn to e5 and then Knight to
f4 and this is really geared towards
players that find themselves loving the
aggressive game giving up material so
that they can have more of an aggressive
style that they can have more pieces
involved into the action so if your
opponent takes Knight to f3 you can play
Bishop here to c4 you can castle have
your rook here on f1 to attack this
semi-open file right here so very very
aggressive if you guys actually want
more videos on let's say the top 10
aggressive openings for whites or
aggressive openings for black let me
know I can make another video but this
is definitely one of the ways that you
want to get your feet wet and understand
if you actually like an aggressive
opening because you could play the
King's gambit and say Mendes is just not
for me once I get down to material like
I just don't know what to do because I
play pretty defensive this would
definitely not be your opening but if
you like to get pieces involved into the
action very very quickly and attack your
opponent the King's gambit is definitely
one of the openings that you you have to
have in your top 10 list
the next opening we're going to be
looking at is probably the most popular
opening for black against pawn to e4 and
that is the Sicilian defense by far the
most popular defense for grandmasters
it's not only the most popular but it
actually scores the best as far as
blacks winning percentage so you'll
usually see this a lot there's a lot of
ways a lot of different variations of
the Sicilian defense you've got the
knight or if you've got the dragon
you've got your classical you've even
got the accelerated drag and all these
different things I've made videos on all
these but but more than anything you
should definitely be familiar with the
Sicilian defense if you're playing
White's you should be pretty familiar
with how to attack the Sicilian defense
there's different gambits that you have
but this is definitely going to be one
of the most common openings in chess
that everyone should definitely know and
have it in their top 10 chess openings
that they know in chess
and last but not least our number one
chest opening is the Queen's game it's a
pawn here to d4 pawn d5 pawn here to c4
you can watch the video on the Queen's
game but it's not a true gambit y can
actually hold on to the material thie
wants to but this is the most common
opening that you'll see now on chess was
it always this way back in the day there
was more of an aggressive style and you
usually see pawn to e4 more than
anything but in the in the queen pawn
game this this Queens gambit is very
very popular so knowing one how to play
this White's because you may like this
type of opening and as far as blacks
concern finding different openings that
you like to defend against this is very
very popular because you're going to see
this more than pretty much any opening
out there so that is my top 10 list of
the chess openings that you should
definitely learn if you're getting into
chess you've been playing chess for a
while and curious you know if you want
to start playing more what openings you
should know these are the top ten if you
guys want more lists again of different
ways that the top 10 hyper modern or
aggressive or passive or just things for
the top 10 ways to attack the Queen's
Gambit or the Kings game but let me know
I can definitely make more videos but
these ten everyone should know and be
pretty familiar with so hopefully you
guys learn something definitely make
sure you check out all the videos for
these ten openings and I'll see you guys
in the next video thanks for watching